so und damit kommen wir jetzt zu einem
etwas anderen Thema bleiben aber in der
Wirtschaft es geht um das Abkommen mit
Kanada das ceta Abkommen also
Wirtschafts- und Handelsabkommen
eigentlich gab es hier einen
Gesetzentwurf und einen Antrag der
Unionsfraktion das wurde jetzt aber erst
einmal von der Tagesordnung genommen
denn hier haben sich die Abgeordneten
auf § 62 Absatz 2 der Geschäftsordnung
bezogen und dieser
Paragraph besagt dass eine Fraktion
verlangen kann dass sich der Bundestag
mit einer Vorlage beschäftigt wenn diese
Vorlage 10 Wochen nach Überweisung immer
noch im Ausschuss liegt und dass
deswegen über den Stand der Beratungen
berichtet werden muss von dem
Ausschussvorsitzenden oder den Bericht
Erstatter und das wurde eben nun hier
verlangt zu einem Gesetzentwurf der
Union
zum Handelsabkommen mit Kanada als
erstes spricht nun dazu Mike außendorf
von Bündnis 90 den Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen
komischerweise erst seit dem
Regierungswechsel drängen sie als Union
auf eine schnelle Ratifizierung des
Handelsabkommens wenn Ihnen das so
wichtig ist warum habe ich das
eigentlich nicht längst erledigt so und
sie wissen nämlich auch ganz genau dass
die Koalition ein Zeitplan verabredet
hat den können Sie nachlesen schon im
Koalitionsvertrag und nach dem Urteil
des Bundesverfassungsgerichts in der
handelspolitischen Agenda so im März im
März 2022 da hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht einige
Rechtsfragen geklärt man muss auch sagen
einige sind noch nicht geklärt und das
gehört zu Wahrheit dazu die endgültige
Entscheidung steht erst nach den bereits
angekündigten klagen für den Falle einer
Ratifizierung durch das Hohe Haus an
Gott so weiter zu
wie im Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart
haben wir nach dem Beschluss des
Verfassungsgerichts die Gespräche über
eine Ratifizierung innerhalb der
Koalition aufgenommen dabei haben wir
uns als grüne auf zwei Punkte
konzentriert erstens die
sonderklagerechte für Konzerne auf
direkt Enteignung einzugrenzen und
zweitens für zukünftige zu
klassifizierende Abkommen die Aufnahme
von verbindlichen
Nachhaltigkeitskriterien sozialen
ökologischen Standards zur Voraussetzung
zu machen
[Applaus]
für die sonderklagerechte wird eine
Erklärung des gemeinsamen Ausschuss
angestrebt der Text ist zwischen der
Kommission und dem Bundesministerium für
Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz abgestimmt
und setzt den Rahmen für die
Schiedsgerichte entsprechend die
Bundesregierung hat hier in kürzester
Zeit geliefert und jahrelang
fehlgeleitete Außenwirtschaftspolitik
bestmöglich schockiert wir haben hier
als grüne für eine fundamentale
Verbesserung gesorgt die Verabschiedung
dieser Erklärung durch den gemeinsamen
Ausschuss ist dabei zwingende
Voraussetzung für unsere Zustimmung zum
ratifizierungsgesetz
für uns sind gründliche und
demokratische Prozesse und enge
parlamentarische Einbindung wichtig
daher stärken wir wie vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht angemahnt die
parlamentarische Einbindung indem wir
einen Unterausschuss zur besseren
Kontrolle der Außenwirtschaftspolitik
der Bundesregierung einsetzen so stärken
wir die parlamentarische Kontrolle nicht
nur von Zita sondern auch aller
zukünftiger Handelsverträge
und an dieser Stelle der Realität zu
begegnen nehmen wir uns für die Zukunft
der Nacht die nachhaltigkeitskapitel des
fertig verhandelten Abkommens mit
Neuseeland zum Vorbild so stellen wir
uns gute und faire Handelsabkommen vor
nach einer endgültigen Ratifizierung von
ceta durch alle Partner werden wir da ja
unmittelbar auch die review-klausel
aufrufen um den Prozess zur
Weiterentwicklung von ceta und zur
Aufnahme von nachhaltigkeitskapiteln
einzuleiten um auch mit Kanada den
Goldstandard nach Vorbild Neuseelands zu
erreichen
für uns Grüne gehörten gemeinsame Werte
Menschenrechtsfragen ökologische und
soziale Aspekte schon immer zu den
Grundpfeilern der Außenhandelspolitik
für uns ein unabdingbarer Selbstzweck
wird nach dem Angriffskrieg Russlands
jetzt auch vielen KritikerInnen klar das
war und ist der richtige Ansatz denn
Handelsbeziehungen mit wertepartnern und
dem gemeinsamen Interesse Klimaschutz
führen zu besonders verlässlichen und
stabilen Handelsbeziehungen auf die wir
auch ins Krisen und Kriegssituationen
verlassen können
[Applaus]
mike außendorf war das grünen
Abgeordneter und für seine Fraktion auch
Berichterstatter im Wirtschaftsausschuss
für die Handelspolitik hat hier noch
einmal erklärt warum es seiner Meinung
nach zu Verzögerungen kommt auf ihn
antworten kann und Stefan ruhen sehr
geehrte Dorf cdu/csu wenn man sich in
diesen Wochen die Bundesregierung
anschaut dann kommt man aus dem Staunen
nun wirklich nicht mehr raus und es gilt
nicht nur für die regierungsehrungen und
Wirrungen in der Energiepolitik sondern
auch in anderen Politikbereichen und
jetzt erzählen Sie Herr aussendorff dass
der von der Bundesregierung
eingeschlagene Weg genau der richtige
ist und ihr Wirtschaftsminister Robert
Habeck stellt sich am Dienstag beim
Parlamentarischen Abend von BDI BDA und
DHK hin und erklärt er und die
Bundesregierung seien die treibende
Kraft bei der Ratifikation
aber ganze 15 Stunden später verhindern
sie SPD Grüne und FDP dass der
Gesetzentwurf der Unionsfraktion zur
ceterratifikation im
Wirtschaftsausschuss zur Sprache kommt
leiden sie leiden sie leiden sie an
Amnesie und der leiden sie ihren
Schizophrenie oder was was sehe ich da
bei der Ampel und ihre Spielchen erleben
wir nicht zum ersten Mal und nicht zum
zweiten Mal und nicht zum dritten Mal
nein
seit zehn Sitzungswochen seit März 2022
weigert sich diese Regierung den
Gesetzentwurf im Wirtschaftsausschuss zu
beraten seit einem halben Jahr
verhindert diese Bundesregierung die
Ratifikation des EU Freihandelsabkommens
mit Kanada einem unserer engsten
Verbündeten das ist ein Armutszeugnis
und da das ist nichts das hat nichts mit
einer treibenden Kraft in der
Handelspolitik zu tun wie Robert Habeck
sie darstellt liebe liebe Kollegen und
Kollegen von der Regierungsfraktion
regen Sie sich nicht so ich bin mir
sicher auch ich bin mir sicher dass sie
auch nicht alles merken was so abgeht
draußen in der Welt und scheinbar hätten
sie auch sonst nicht so geredet Herr
Herr außendorf ihre Politik sorgt für
Irritationen und Frustration und das
nicht nur bei uns als
Oppositionsfraktion im August reiste
Kanzler Scholz und Minister Habeck nach
Kanada um der kanadischen Regierung die
deutschen Sonderwünsche für die
Ratifikation von ceta mitzuteilen sie
haben es sie haben es erwähnt es geht um
die interpretationserklärung zu den
ceta-investitionsschutzbestimmung und
ich kann Ihnen sagen die Begeisterung
war darüber riesengroß riesengroß
genauso wie übrigens bei der
Europäischen Kommission und warum ist
das so weil diese Erklärung
ausschließlich parteipolitisch motiviert
ist einer grünen Parteipolitik
geschuldet ist und weil sie nur noch
einmal das ganz klar unterstreicht was
der ceta-vertragstext ohnehin schon
längst vorsießt sie gern hier etwas
Falsches und ich sage auch an dieser
Stelle so geht man nicht mit Ängsten
Verbündeten wie Kanada um
und wer mal den Blick nach Europa
richtet und mal genau zuhört der sieht
dass einige EU-Mitgliedstaaten die Nase
gestrichen voll haben dass Deutschland
immer eine extrawurstpolitik hier
betreibt und meine Damen und Herren die
wirtschaftliche Lage in unserem Land hat
sich in den vergangenen Monaten deutlich
verschlechtert Lieferketten sind durch
den Krieg in der Ukraine und durch die
corona-pandemie nachhaltig gestört die
Inflation schießt durch die Decke
deutschland steuert auf eine Rezession
zu Liebe ampelkollegen eine deutsche
extrawurstpolitik ist wirklich das
Letzte was wir jetzt brauchen machen sie
machen sie endlich das was in dieser
krisenhaften Zeit dringend erforderlich
ist sorgen Sie dafür dass Deutschland
endlich wieder eine proaktive Rolle in
der eu-handelspolitik einnimmt treten
sie in Brüssel mit Nachdruck für neue
Freihandelsabkommen ein um neue
Absatzmärkte zu erschließen die
Exportchancen der deutschen Wirtschaft
zu vergrößern unsere Handelsbeziehungen
zu diversifizieren also auf ein breites
Fundament zu stellen und um Wohlstand
und Beschäftigung in unserem Land zu
sichern und meine Damen und Herren ceta
ist das eine ceta ist ein wichtiges
Abkommen und ich hoffe sehr dass wir das
dass sie das nicht noch weiter auf die
lange Bank schieben aber eine noch
größere ökonomische und strategische
Bedeutung hat das EU merkurabkommen mit
über 700 Millionen Menschen und einem
Anteil von fast 20 Prozent an der
weltweiten Wirtschaftsleistung ist es
das größte jemals von der EU-Kommission
ausgehandelte ab es ermöglicht uns neue
wirtschaftliche Beziehungen zu bisher
stark abgeschotteten Ländern das
Abkommen ist bereits seit mehreren
Jahren ausgehandelt aber auch hier
stoppt die Ratifikation und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Ampel
stellen Sie unter Beweis dass Sie die
Zeichen der Zeit erkannt haben haben
springen sie über ihren
parteipolitischen Schatten beenden sie
endlich endlich die Blockade bei der
ceter Ratifikation und stärken sie die
eu-handelspolitik in dem sie in Brüssel
für die Ratifikation des eu-märktes
zuabkommens mit Nachdruck eintreten das
mit Nachdruck vorantreiben denn wir
brauchen auch mit dieser Weltregion eine
viel engere Zusammenarbeit und das nicht
nur um die Folgen der vor uns liegenden
Wirtschaftskrise abzufedern sondern auch
um geostrategisch nicht unter die Räder
zu kommen herzlichen Dank
stefan ruhenhoff war das für die
Unionsfraktion auf ihn folgt nun Markus
Töns der für die SPD-Fraktion der
zuständige Berichterstatter in dieser
Thematik ceta ist
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich habe
elf Minuten das wird
reichen um mal vielleicht ein paar Dinge
klar zu stellen vielleicht brauche ich
die auch gar nicht ich sitze aber es ist
ich versuche es mal auf elf zu Minute zu
bringen die Chance dass ich über CSR
gering
das ist ja das was sie im Ausschuss
immer haben ne nicht zu sagen das
stellen wir doch immer wieder fest oder
ist doch so ist doch so Frau Klöppner
also Herr ruhnhoff ist schon ist schon
interessant dass sie hier heute von
ihnen sind zehn Abgeordnete da bei
diesem Punkt der sie so interessiert das
muss ja eine Herzensangelegenheit sein
die sie hier heute Mittag abziehen wo
sind was los was ist los das ist das
wichtige Thema dass sie jetzt hier
vertreten ist doch lächerlich Frau
Klöckner ist doch lächerlich machen sich
doch nichts vor und habe ich ihn noch
was sagen es ist auch schon ein Ding der
ratifizieren in diesem Jahr ganz zu in
Ruhe ganz in Ruhe ganz geschmeidig aber
ich erzähle ihnen hören Sie mir doch mal
zu vielleicht hilft das ja zur
Wahrheitsfindung übrigens hätte es auch
was genutzt ein bisschen mal in die
Dinge zu gucken die wir dazu auch schon
veröffentlicht haben dann müssten sie
auch wohin der Weg geht aber lassen wir
das mal der stellen Sie sich jetzt hier
hin her ruhen hofft sie stellen sich
hier und sagen das mit der Erklärung die
wir jetzt auf dem Weg bringen dass wir
damit die europäischen Partner alle
verunsichern ja ich frage mal nach was
hat was hat denn ihre Union in 16 Jahren
unter Angela Merkel hier an
Verunsicherung in Europa gemacht ich
will sie nur daran erinnern die
Finanzkrise hat zur größten
Verunsicherung geführt weil ihr
Finanzminister und ihre Kanzlerin
nämlich nicht in der Lage waren dafür
Ruhe zu sorgen
Griechenland aus dem Euro ausschließen
zu wollen war ein Beispiel dafür warum
wir in Europa beispielsweise kritisch
gesehen werden das sollten Sie sich mal
auf die erfahrene schreiben und nicht
hier solche merkwürdigen merkwürdigen
Anträge was haben wir denn jetzt hier
vorliegen wir haben ein Gesetzentwurf
der Union der seit zehn Wochen geschoben
wird sie haben das Recht nach der
Geschäftsordnung 62 einen Bericht zu
verlangen so sie bekommen den Bericht
heute der Bericht ist Jena wir haben
einen eigenen Gesetzentwurf eingebracht
nachdem wir nachdem wir uns das
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil in Ruhe
angeschaut haben wir haben uns dann
interkoalition wir haben uns in der
Koalition darauf verständigt diesen
einzubringen der ist eingebracht
mittlerweile hat der
Wirtschaftsausschuss das wissen sie auch
der Wirtschaftsausschuss eine Anhörung
beschlossen für den 12 Oktober nur zur
Erinnerung falls den Termin schon wieder
vergessen haben und dann würde ich sie
noch daran erinnern
dass sie auch nicht schlecht sie hätten
ja auch ihren Gesetzentwurf an diese
Anhörung anhängen können das haben wir
Ihnen angeboten das wollten sie aber
nicht sie wollten vereinigte nein sie
nehmen an der Anhörung Teil aber sie
wollen Ihren Gesetzentwurf warum warum
denn nicht da gibt es auch keine
Begründung für nein es ist einfach nur
sie wollen hier heute Mittag ein
bisschen klamau veranstalten und wenn
Sie das so gerne wollen dann werden
frage ich sie wir haben Fragen ich sie
ernsthaft wo ihre staatspolitische
Verantwortung
so wir werden weitere Beratungen haben
nachdem die Anhörung da ist wir werden
uns das ganze in Ruhe angucken und dann
werden wir das in diesem Herbst
beschließen und darauf können Sie sich
verlassen darauf können Sie sich
verlassen weil nämlich all das was wir
jetzt machen auch in der Erklärung was
in der Erklärung steht wird beinhaltet
nichts anderes als dass wir noch mal
klären dass das auch im Vertrag
vorhanden ist und es ist im Vertrag
waren also müssen wir da überhaupt gar
nicht nervös werden und dann will ich
noch mal auf einen Punkt hinweisen der
aus meiner Sicht übrigens noch mal
wichtig ist warum man übrigens auch auf
dem richtigen Weg ist nicht nur in der
Koalition sondern auch mit diesem
Vertrag wir sind in einer vollkommen
anderen Situation als noch vor vielen
Jahren übrigens vielleicht nur eine
Bemerkung am Rand Zita wie es in der
vorläufigen Anwendung seit fünf Jahren
jetzt genau im September sind es fünf
Jahre so die vorläufige Anwendung
funktioniert es gibt keine Verwerfung in
diesem Vertrag keine großen Probleme so
und wir werden deshalb auch ratifizieren
aber ich will noch mal auf etwas
weiteres Hinweisen sie schon sehr wohl
das nämlich allein
gestatten Sie eine Frage oder Bemerkung
des Kollegen runhoff
lieber Herr schöns jetzt hören wir ja
vieles aus Brüsseler Ebene und es gibt
sehr sehr kritische Stimmen von den
Mitgliedstaaten zu genau dieser
deutschen interpretationserklärung ich
möchte gerne wissen wie sie die
Situation in Brüssel einschätzen ob sie
einmal glauben dass wir auf Brüsseler
dass sie auf Brüsseler Ebene mit ihrer
interpretationserklärung durchkommen und
ich möchte gerne mal wissen ob sie damit
auch eine Präzedenzwirkung sehen mit
ihrer
interpretations-staaten in der
Europäischen Union fürchten dass
Deutschland immer wieder Extrawürste
anmeldet
vielen Dank für die Frage dann will ich
darauf zweier zweigeteilte auf Antworten
das ist keine Extrawurst
sondern es geht darum dass wir das was
im Vertrag steht noch mal in einer
Erklärung mit unseren Partnerinnen und
Partnern in der Europäischen Union
diesen Vertrag anhängen das ist keine
Vertragsänderung damit ist damit auch
nicht verbunden dass sich irgendetwas
ändert sondern wir erklären noch mal was
sich inhaltlich in diesem vertragliche
und wissen Sie warum wir das eigentlich
tun das ist nämlich etwas worauf wir
eingehen sie wissen ganz genau dass vor
vielen Jahren als ceta in der
endverhandlung war das ist erhebliche
erhebliche Proteste aus der Bürgerschaft
gab diese Proteste haben uns dazu
gebracht genau hin zu gucken und den
Menschen mit auf dem Weg zu geben dass
wir hier einen Vertrag zustimmen der
auch ihren Interessen entspricht darum
geht es inhaltlich in dieser Sache und
ich sage Ihnen auch ich bin da ganz bin
ja ganz nah übrigens auch bei der
Staatsministerin bei der der
parlamentarischen Staatssekretärin
Franziska Brandner die
sehr eindeutig auch in den Berichten der
ihnen ja vorliegt auch im Ausschuss
erklärt hat dass die Gespräche auf einem
guten Weg sind und dass die Partnerin
und Partner diesen am Ende auch
zustimmen ich kann da nicht erkennen
dass wir da nervös werden müssen also
vor dem Hintergrund eine Extrawurst ist
das nun wirklich nicht
[Applaus]
auf den multilateralen
investitionsrichtung kommen dieser
multilaterale investitionsgerichtshof
ist nämlich genau das was diesen Vertrag
auch zu etwas Besonderem macht und wenn
uns das gelingt dass wir den jetzt
gratifizieren und davon bin ich zutiefst
überzeugt dass das in diesem Herbst
passieren wird dann werden wir auch
diesen multilateralen
investitionsgericht sobald wenn alle
Staaten in Europa wir sind übrigens
nicht die letzten wie Sie wissen
ratifiziert haben dass wir den dann auch
im Weg bringen und das ist eine
substanzielle Verbesserung des Rechts
und eine substanzielle Zelle
Verbesserung für das was ist nämlich
Investoren müssen sich dann vor einem
Gericht für ein Gericht bewegen das
wirklich mit Richterinnen und Richtern
ausgestattet ist das Recht spricht und
nicht ein
intransparentes Schiedsverfahren
beinhaltet und deshalb alleine ist es
gut dass wir in diesem Herbst
ratifizieren sie können ganz beruhigt
sein setz nicht wieder hinnehmen sie an
der Anhörung Teil wir freuen uns darauf
auf Ihre Fragen und wir werden am Ende
diesen Vertrag ratif ganz in Ruhe glück
auf
das Wort hat der Abgeordnete Bernd
Schattner für die afd-
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
da die Koalition zehnmal die Aussprache
in Wirtschaftsausschuss verweigert hat
befassen wir uns heute also mit dem
Bericht der Koalition zu den hier
vorliegenden Anträgen der CDU
zusammengefasst kann man zu diesen
Anträgen sagen bei der CDU ist man wohl
frei nach dem Motto vorgegangen je mehr
desto besser anders ist es nicht zu
erklären dass man von ceta über den
Handel mit der USA über Japan bis nach
Mexiko Chile und die anderen
Andengemeinschaft einfach alle einbinden
möchte
liebe Kollegen der CDU sie sollten sich
schon entscheiden was sie überhaupt
wollen wie wichtig Handel ist erleben
wir gerade in unserer heutigen Zeit und
auch wir als AFD stehen im freien
Welthandel grundsätzlich positiv
gegenüber aber in das sage ich ihnen
deutlich Handel mit Augenmaß und das
scheinen sie in diesem Antrag verloren
zu haben insbesondere auch im Hinblick
auf über 200.000 Kläger beim
Bundesverfassungsgericht die geplante
Installation von supranationalen
Schiedsgerichten ist nichts anderes als
die Aufgabe unserer nationalen
Gerichtsbarkeit erneut fordert die
Europäische Union dass wir Teile unserer
Judikative an sie übertragen eine
weitere Abgabe nationaler Souveränität
ist mit uns eben nicht zu machen
diese Übertragung wäre ein weiterer
Schritt in Richtung Aushöhlung unseres
Nationalstaates Gott sei Dank teilt das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hier unsere
Auffassung dass diese Übertragung mit
dem Grundgesetz eben nicht vereinbar
wäre meine Damen und Herren ein weiterer
Punkt in diesem Abkommen dem wir so
nicht zustimmen werden ist die zollfreie
Einfuhr von 45.000 Tonnen Rindfleisch
75.000 Tonnen Schweinefleisch und
hunderttausend Euro 100.000 Tonnen
Weichweizen bereits in den letzten
Jahren standen unsere Bauern mit dem
Rücken zur Wand vor allem die
unterbrochenen Lieferketten die
corona-maßnahmen und eben nicht auch
zuletzt der Krieg in der Ukraine haben
unseren Bauern an den Rand der Existenz
gebracht und die Lage verschlechtert
sich täglich weiter durch die immer
weiter steigenden Preise für Dünger für
Energie wäre der billige Import nur noch
der letzte Sargnagel der das Schicksal
unserer Bauern endgültig besiegeln würde
das kann ich in unserem nationalen
Interesse sein unsere Bibliothek muss es
sein zuerst die heimische Landwirtschaft
zu schützen bevor wir Fleisch und andere
landwir deutliche Produkte importieren
hier gilt es zuallererst unsere Bauern
zu schützen und wenn uns die letzten
zwei Jahre eins gezeigt haben dann doch
die Notwendigkeit eine gewisse
Eigenversorgung der Bevölkerung sowohl
mit Nahrungsmitteln als auch sonstigen
wirtschaftlichen Gütern sicherzustellen
dies würde sowohl Deutschland als
Marktmacht in der Welt Stärken als auch
die eigene Bevölkerung im
Versorgungsbereich absichern dieses Ziel
würden mit den hier vorgetragenen
Inhalten unterminiert werden als
demokratische Oppositionspartei stehen
wir wie ich bereits vorhin erwähnt habe
Handelsbeziehungen grundsätzlich offen
gegenüber mit uns wird es aber weder
eine Aufweichung des Verbots von
genveränderten und Hormon belasteten
Lebensmitteln geben noch werden wir
Maßnahmen unterstützen die die heimische
Landwirtschaft noch stärker belasten
sie verzögern im übrigen hier bewusst
einen Antrag der Opposition Liebe
Koalition nur weil es mir in eigenen
Antrag zu langsam waren und das hier der
CDU entlasten wollen dieses wieder ein
sehr gutes Beispiel dass sie der Aufgabe
in dieser Regierung zu sein nicht
gewachsen sind ihre geplante ökologische
Transformation wird auch hier wieder als
Katastrophe entlarvt an ihrem
linksgrünen wirtschaftspolitischen ihr
Weg kleben sie genauso fest wie die
klimaaktivisten von Extension Rebellion
hier bei uns in Berlin auf den Straßen
deswegen sollten Sie sich doch besser
überlegen ihre Regierungsverantwortung
zur Verfügung zu stellen damit dieses
Land wieder eine Aussicht auf bessere
Zeiten hat bevor sie es komplett
heruntergewirtschaftet und an die Wand
gefahren haben vielen Dank
dann Schattner war das für die
afd-fraktion auf ihn folgt nun Karl
Julius Kronenberg er ist der Sprecher
für Mittelstand und Freihandel der
FDP-Fraktion und hier gab es einen
Wechsel auf dem präsidiumberg
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
der Union ganz ehrlich ihre
Debattenbeiträge
wenn ich das so vergleiche mit denen der
letzten Jahre haben mir bis vorhin
eigentlich in dieser Wahlperiode besser
gefallen als in der letzten aber ich
nehme an das hängt ursächlich mit ihrer
neuen Rolle auf der Oppositionsbank
zusammen
möge diese Arbeitsteilung sie halten
gefällige reden wir ratifizieren endlich
ceta bauen elendit Terminals auf und
erneuerbare Energien aus möge diese neue
Arbeitsteilung noch lange Zeit erhalten
bleiben die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
werden das zu schätzen wissen
mit dem mit dem Freihandel verhält es
sich ähnlich wie mit dem Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien was im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart ist wird
durch putinskrieg noch wichtiger und
noch dringlicher die Demokratien der
Welt werden ihre Allianz stärken und
ihre Abhängigkeiten überwinden im
Energiesektor im Rohstoffsektor im
Halbleitersektor wir werden mehr
Handelsabkommen schließen untereinander
und mit dem Rest der Welt das ist das
Gebot der Stunde erneuerbare Energien
sind freiheitsenergien
handelspartnerschaften sind
freiheitspartnerschaften liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die baldige
die baldige ceta Ratifizierung ist ein
starkes Signal für die deutsche
Wirtschaft die Zölle sind schon weg die
Potenziale aber bei weitem noch nicht
ausgeschöpft Investoren auf beiden
Seiten des Atlantiks stehen seit Jahren
in den Startlöchern und warten auf
rechts zum Planungssicherheit nicht nur
Konzerne übrigens sondern auch der
deutsche Mittelstand seit der
vorläufigen Anwendung von ceta hat sich
der Markt Zugang positiv entwickelt ohne
Zölle und Doppel Zertifizierungen stieg
das deutsch-kanatische Handelsvolumen
allein im letzten Jahr im neuen Prozent
ich sage da geht noch mehr ich wünsche
mir dass wir in zehn Jahren in weniger
als zehn Jahren mehr aus Kanada
importieren als aus Russland
da müssen wir hin liebe Kolleginnen sie
wissen
sie wissen was sie ceteratifizierung
anbetrifft hatten die Koalitionspartner
unterschiedliche Ausgangspositionen für
uns liberale hätte es
keiner zusätzlichen Klarstellung bedurft
für die Grünen war die Zustimmung zu
Ratifizierung ein weiter Weg die
liberale sehen die Chancen von
umfassenden Handelsabkommen wir sind
überzeugt dass sie bessere Standards
bringen ceta ist ein Blick dafür Kanada
hat zwei weitere ILO Übereinkommen
angenommen andere sehen das Risiko das
über die missbräuchliche Anwendung von
investitionsschutzstandards
Standards geschliffen werden oder
starten in ihrer Klimapolitik
eingeschränkt werden können wir teilen
diese Bedenken nicht und doch nehmen wir
sie sehr ernst
es ist uns wichtig dass am Ende des
Prozesses ein breiter Konsens über die
Vertiefung der Partnerschaft mit Kanada
steht einem breiter politischer und
gesellschaftlicher Konsens liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das ist uns
wichtig und wenn und wenn es so ist und
wenn es so ist dass für diesen breiten
Konsens eine interpretationserklärung in
Form einer Klarstellung hilft dann ist
es auch gut wenn wir uns die Zeit dafür
nehmen die es braucht liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
mir ist es wichtig und ich sage es Ihnen
warum bedürfen und wir wollen nicht in
keinander stehen bleiben vielmehr wollen
soll dieser Prozess ermutigen
Sprungbrett sein für weitere
Freihandelsabkommen zum Beispiel mit
Chile dort liegen wichtige Rohstoffe für
Halbleiter und Batterien für
Elektroautos ohne Lithium keine
Batterien und weniger Chips auch für
Mexiko und Merkur ist alles angesprochen
worden wollen wir voranschreiten
Australien Indien chancenkontinent
Afrika zeitenwände soll für Europa
heißen weniger Abhängigkeiten durch mehr
Resilienz durch mehr Diversität im
Handel
warenhandelsabkommen schon immer ein
Gebot der ökonomischen Vernunft so sind
sie heute ein Gebot der neuen
geopolitischen Realität Deutschland
[Applaus]
S ist die viertgrößte Volkswirtschaft
der Welt und die größte in Europa
Deutschland macht allein mehr als 25
Prozent des eu-außenhandels aus unsere
Partner erwarten dass Deutschland in
Europa Verantwortung übernimmt und
entschlossen voranschreitet was sie
nicht mehr wollen sind deutsche
Alleingänge aller nordstream 2 ich rate
uns dringend davon ab in der
Handelspolitik die Fehler der
Energiepolitik zu wiederholen
Verantwortung übernehmen ist etwas
anderes als Alleingänge durchzudrücken
nicht alles lieber Mike aus dem Dorf
nicht alles was mit Neuseeland geht wird
auch mit Indien sofort gelingen mit
gesundem Selbstbewusstsein sagen wir wir
sind die bessere Alternative zu China im
globalen Süden und noch besser mit
Handels ob Abkommen als ohne das sollte
uns auch dann leiten wenn wir nicht
alles was wünschenswert ist gleich im
ersten Schritt erreichen kommen Sie
bitte zu diesem Herr Kollege in diesem
Herbst in diesem Herbst ratifizieren wir
ceta das ist ein gutes Zeichen in
schlechten Zeiten
sagt Karl Julius Cronenberg wurde hier
von
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin Aydan ösus
noch mal an seine Zeit erinnert
als nächstes erhält Christian Laie für
die Linke das Wort und Christian
laiersprecher für Wirtschaftspolitik der
Linksfraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren worum geht es es geht
darum dass mit ceta internationale
Konzerne die Möglichkeit bekommen sollen
gegen demokratische Entscheidung zum
Beispiel hier im Bundestag vor
Sondergerichten zu klagen das müsste
doch eigentlich zu einem Aufschrei unter
allen DemokratInnen und Demokraten
führen wollen sie als Gesetzgeber
wirklich beschließen dass sie Konzernen
keine Gesetze mehr geben können ohne
dass die sie vor ein Sondergericht
ziehen Frage in die Runde wenn Sie
denken dass sie als Gesetzgeber für
Konzerne nicht geeignet sind warum sagen
Sie das nicht ihren Wählerinnen und
Wählern aber darüber wird kaum
gesprochen stattdessen reden wir über
Werte und sie wollen uns weismachen dass
gerade jetzt in der Energiekrise ceta
notwendig sei und ich will jetzt mal an
Fallbeispielen erklären warum genau das
Gegenteil richtig ist so gab es übrigens
in Kanada vollkommen zu Recht Widerstand
der Bevölkerung gegen Fracking durch den
Öl- und gehaltskonzern Lohn Pein 100
Bürgerinitiativen werden sich mehr als
30.000 Menschen unterzeichnen
Online-Petitionen die Provinzregierung
stoppte das Fracking und fand sich vor
einem Sondergericht wieder wo sie von
dem Konzern auf Millionensummen verklagt
wurden Frage in die Runde warum wollen
Sie sich beim Abwägen zwischen
Energieförderung und Umweltschutz
derartig die Hände binden lassen
aktuelles Beispiel aus Italien
da verklagt das Öl vor der Unternehmer
Unternehmen Rockoper den italienischen
Staat weil nach Protesten aus der
Bevölkerung in einer zwölf meilen-zone
vor der Küste kein Öl mehr gefördert
werden darf vor allem privaten
Schiedsgericht hat der Konzern dann
recht bekommen der italienische Staat
muss 190 Millionen Euro zahlen weil er
seine Bevölkerung schützen wollte Frage
in die Runde wollen sie in Sachen
Ölförderung wirklich zuerst die Konzerne
fragen bevor sie ihre eigenen
Wählerinnen und Wähler Fragen so den
Vogel abschießen tut der Energiekonzern
uniper denn das Unternehmen verklagt
gerade den niederländischen Staat vor
einem Schiedsgericht der Konzern fordert
knapp eine Milliarden Euro weil in den
Niederlanden die Regierung die
Kohleverstromung bis 2030 einige aus bis
2030 aus der Kohle aussteigen will Frage
in die Runde wenn uniper jetzt
verstaatlicht werden soll
verklagt dann die deutsche
Bundesregierung die niederländische
Bundesregierung weil die etwas wollen
was wir so ähnlich auch wollen das ist
doch der Wahnsinn in Tüten und deswegen
zur Energiekrise und zu ceta sie ändern
doch gerade im Wochentag ihre
Energiepolitik weil sie ehrlich gesagt
keinen Plan haben wie wir durch diesen
Winter kommen sollen gaspreisdeckel
Verstaatlichung ein neues
strommarktdesign übergewinnsteuer
Preiskontrollen für welche dieser
Maßnahmen könnte man sich eigentlich vor
einem Sondergericht wiederfinden weil
die irgendeinem Energiekonzern nicht
passen das ist doch der absolute
Wahnsinn und deswegen kein Demokrat und
keine Demokratin hat das Recht vor dem
Internationalen Kapital derartig auf den
Knien zu rutschen sagen sie Nein zu
diesem Abkommen danke schön
für Bündnis 90 die Grünen bekommt Dieter
Janecek das Wort Dieter Janecek ist
wirtschaftspolitische Sprecher seiner
Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin kanada ist
ein enger Freund und Partner der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland
in der Substanz reden wir hier über das
Freihandelsabkommen ceta dass wir
Kronenberg gesagt hat seit fünf Jahren
in der vorläufigen Anwendung ist und als
gutes Abkommen funktioniert und auch im
letzten Jahr noch mal einen Zuwachs im
Freihandel von neun Prozent bekommen hat
die Frage warum reagsrecht reden über
die Ratifizierung hat er mit folgendem
Sachverhalt zu tun die große Skepsis der
zivilbevölker Zivilgesellschaft und auch
Teile des Parlaments in Bezug auf die
Schiedsgerichte
und es war und es gibt zahlreiche
Beispiele der Vergangenheit wo
schiedsgerichtsbarkeiten zum Missbrauch
eingeladen haben und auch Fälle wo
dieser Missbrauch stattgefunden hat und
deswegen war es uns jetzt ein Anliegen
wie übrigens auch elf weiteren Staaten
der Europäischen Union diesen Bereich
der Schiedsgerichte einzugrenzen und
eine Verabredung zu finden zwischen
Deutschland und Kanada aber letztlich
dann auch innerhalb der gesamten
Europäischen Union um diesen Bereich
wirklich einzugrenzen ausschließlich auf
den Bereich der direkten Enteignung um
kein Missbrauch mehr vorkommen zu lassen
darum ging es in der Substanz der
letzten Wochen und ich danke der
Staatssekretärin branten und der
Bundesregierung dass sie hier und auch
der gesamten Koalition dass wir diesen
Weg gegangen sind und diesen Passus
jetzt erreicht haben
es geht ja darüber hinaus auch dass wir
Skepsis ernst nehmen wir wollen den
Freihandel vertiefen wir werden auch
schwierige Diskussionen haben auch das
mercosurabkommen werden wir sicherlich
nicht dann abschließen können wir wir
nicht zu Regelungen kommen das Schutzes
des Amazonas dort auch die Wahlen in
Brasilien werden da eine Rolle spielen
das heißt wir können uns die Partner auf
der Welt zwar nicht aussuchen aber wir
müssen auch für unsere Werte einstehen
in der Welt auch das gehört zusammen
und deswegen wollen wir auch die
parlamentarische Kontrolle Stärken es
wird ein Unterausschuss geben der sich
regelmäßig mit den bestehenden
Freihandelsabkommen befasst das ist der
richtige Weg um nicht nur unsere Werte
auch unsere Interessen aber auch das
Funktionieren von Freihandelsabkommen
parlamentarisch zu kontrollieren genau
diesen Weg werden wir gehen
das Thema Liebe Union der Nachhaltigkeit
was sie ja oft so als Nebenschauplatz
versucht haben zu formulieren ist aber
auch ein ganz zentrales selbst im
Freihandelsabkommens Täter stehen da ja
sehr relevante Sätze drin ich darf
zitieren das verhältnisabkommen ist auch
dazu da das wirtschaftliche Entwicklung
soziale Entwicklung und Umweltschutz
sich gegenseitig beeinflussen und
verstärken und das ist ein Momentum dass
wir auch für künftige
Freihandelsabkommen der goldstandes ist
Neuseeland nutzen wollen das heißt es
geht darum auch dieses level playing
field im Bereich Klimaschutz
Nachhaltigkeit
ILO Arbeitsnorm soziale Standards zu
verhandeln wir wissen die Welt ist nicht
immer so wie sie uns wünschen aber Sie
können davon ausgehen dass das auch
Positionen der Europäischen Union ist
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland dieser
Bundesregierung künftige
freiheitsabkommen darauf zu überprüfen
dass wir möglichst viel von dem
durchsetzen was ja zum Wohle der
gesamten Welt ist nämlich dass wir eine
klimaebene finden wo wir gemeinsam
handeln finden und dass wir nicht
Handeltreiben um Umwelt zu zerstören
soziale Standard zu schleifen sondern um
Wohlstand zu schaffen sozial und ÖK ich
bedanke mich für diese Debatte
und damit kommen wir hier zum letzten
Redner in dieser Debatte das ist Thomas
Silberhorn er spricht für die
Unionsfraktion
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
wir müssen diese heutige Debatte nicht
führen wenn die Bundesregierung und
diese Ampelkoalition den endlich
entscheiden würden
das täte-abkommen ist 20 16 paraviert
worden damit wurde der Vertragstext als
verbindlich fixiert es wird seit 2017
angewandt also seit über fünf Jahren ja
es gab verfassungsrechtliche Bedenken
aus dieser Ecke aus der SPD-Fraktion
aber die sind mittlerweile ausgeräumt
das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat die
Verfassungsbeschwerden und die
Organstreitverfahren am 9 Februar diesen
Jahres zurückgewiesen das ist über
sieben Monate her sie haben ganze fünf
Monate gebraucht um einen Gesetzentwurf
vorzulegen und den wälzen sie jetzt ein
ums andere Mal hin und her und kommen
nicht zu Potte
wir reden über zwei Artikel mit jeweils
zwei Sätzen das ist nicht einmal eine
halbe DIN A4 Seite und das kriegen sie
nicht auf die Reihe meine Damen und
Herren sie haben immerhin
sie haben immerhin und das ist neu heute
in Aussicht gestellt dass sie
ratifizieren werden aber sie haben
natürlich mit dieser Debatte auch
deutlich gemacht da sie nach wie vor
alle mit sich selbst beschäftigt sind
diese ampelkollektion und diese
Bundesregierung müssen endlich in den
Arbeitsmodus schalten meine Damen und
Herren die Ratifikation des
zederabkommens ist längst
entscheidungsreif
aber statt zu entscheiden wird das
monatelang hin und hergewälzt und der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister beklagt sich
öffentlich seine Leute würden unter
Burnout leiden nach nicht mal einem Jahr
unter seiner Führung also mich wundert
das nicht wenn man selbst einfache
Vorhaben monatelang und ohne Ergebnis
hin und her schiebt das muss ja krank
machen es fällt schon auf dass sie bei
Katar und bei Saudi-Arabien nicht so
pingelig sind meine Damen und Herren
die Europäischen Union teilt mit Kanada
so viele Normen und Standards wie mit
kaum einem anderen Land außerhalb der
Europäischen Union mit dem ceta-abkommen
entfallen 98 Prozent der Zölle zwischen
der EU und Kanada das ist nach
Schätzungen der EU-Kommission eine
Entlastung von fast 600 Millionen Euro
jährlich und mit der rautifizierung
würden Europäische Union und Kanada ihr
öffentliches Auftragswesen auf Landes-
und kommunalsebene gegenseitig öffnen
die sozialen ökologischen Standards die
auf beiden Seiten hoch sind würden
angeglichen und ja es würde auch ein
moderner Investitionsschutz eingeführt
der meine Damen und Herren keine
kanadische Idee ist sondern auf eine
Initiative der Europäischen Union
zurückgeht weil man sich unter den
damals 28 Mitgliedsstaaten eben nicht
darauf verständigen konnte einen
nationale Rechtsordnung zu berufen für
Streitigkeiten aus diesem Abkommen
und das alles meine Damen und Herren
jetzt zur ratifizieren liegt natürlich
in unserem Interesse unsere
Volkswirtschaft funktioniert nur mit
Rohstoffen und Energie davon haben wir
aber zu wenig in Deutschland und deshalb
brauchen wir Partner in der EU und
außerhalb der Europäischen Union mit
denen wir tragfähige Lieferbeziehungen
unterhalten können Kanada ist hier ein
zuverlässiger transatlantischer Partner
der für uns künftig noch wichtiger sein
wird
und umgekehrt meine Damen und Herren
können wir als deutsche Produkte
anbieten die weltweit gefragt sind dafür
investieren wir in Bildung und Forschung
dafür entwickeln wir neue Technologien
und neue Materialien und darauf beruht
unser Wohlstand darauf nämlich dass es
für unsere Produkte für made in Germany
auf der ganzen Welt Kunden gibt das
meine Damen und Herren ist das
wirtschaftliche Rückgrat für Deutschland
und für den europäischen Binnenmarkt und
deshalb sind insbesondere wir als
Exportnation auf gute Handelsbeziehungen
angewiesen
meine Damen und Herren diese Grundlage
unsere Wirtschaftsordnung von
Arbeitsplätzen Einkommen und Wohlstand
wird weiter erheblich an Bedeutung
gewinnen in diesen transatlantischen
Beziehungen auch weil Russland mit
seinem Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine
das Feld völlig verändert hat und weil
mit China neue Herausforderungen ins
Haus stehen anhalte Lieferengpässe und
Abhängigkeiten auch von China sind
spätestens seit der corona-pandemie ja
für jedermann sichtbar geworden wenn wir
uns aus Abhängigkeiten von
autokratischen Staaten befreien wollen
dann müssen wir unsere Wirtschafts- und
Handelspolitik neu ausrichten und das
bedeutet insbesondere dass wir die
tanzatlantischen Wirtschaftsbeziehungen
ausbauen müssen meine Damen und Herren
die
Ratifikation des zederabkommens ist
dafür nur ein Auftakt weitere Schritte
müssen folgen die Ratifikation des
Merkurs vorabkommens die Verhandlungen
mit Schiele müssen fortgeführt werden
das Abkommen mit Mexiko muss
aktualisiert werden wir brauchen einen
neuen Aufbruch kommt den
transatlantischen Wirtschaftsbeziehungen
mit Kanada auch mit den USA auch mit dem
globalen Süden in meine Damen und Herren
wenn wir jetzt einen schwierigen Winter
vor uns haben mit hoher Kollege kommen
Sie bitte zum Schluss Rezession dann
muss man sehen dass die Löcher die da
gerissen werden nicht allein mit
Steuergeld gestoppt werden können es
braucht auch einen neuen
wirtschaftlichen Aufbruch dafür weist
der Antrag der Union den richtigen Weg
und dafür ist die Ratifikation des
zederabkommens dringend notwendig vielen
Dank
[Applaus]
damit schließe ich die Aussprache